monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre des solidarités de la santé
à l'heure où plus de mille médecins
hospitaliers dont six en chef de service
vous envoyer une lettre démission
collective pour protester contre le
dramatique désastreux et récurrent
manque de moyens de notre hôpital public
au delà d'un cri désespéré de nos
soignants après des années de souffrance
dans leurs services c'est un véritable
burnout et tout notre corps hospitalier
que nous assistons les conditions de
travail sont telles qu'elle remettait en
cause la qualité des soins et menacent
la sécurité des patients les médecins et
les personnels paramédicaux ne sont pas
des machines
ce sont des êtres humains qui consacrent
leur vie à soigner et sauver les autres
notre hôpital public est en
déliquescence
il s'ouvre il se meurt parce qu'il est
au bord de l'asphyxié
nous sommes en état d'urgence faut-il
arriver à un drame pour que votre
gouvernement réagisse enfin les mesures
annoncées le 20 novembre sont
symboliques clairement insuffisante et
n'ont pas convaincu parce qu'elles n'ont
rien d'un plan d'urgence mais plutôt de
communication seule une vraie réforme en
profondeur de notre système de santé
pourra sauver notre hôpital public et
cela passe par des décisions immédiates
forte et courageuse initie un vrai
grenet grenelle de la santé rénover la
gouvernance en sortant de l'inflation
bureaucratique rééquilibrer le pouvoir
entre l'administration et les médecins
revaloriser les salaires engager du
personnel et les doter de moyens et
d'équipements moderniser ouvrir des lits
madame la ministre vous avez été un
médecin hospitalo universitaires vous ne
pouvez pas laisser mourir l'hôpital car
à travers lui c'est ta santé de tous les
français qui est en jeu madame la
ministre
face à cette situation ou allez tous
vous